j'aurai enfin te faire une interview
heures c'est moi qui vais te la faire
c'est vrai que tu étais chez m barthez
mon quotidien c'est vrai qu'on sera le
beaucoup tous les deux je vais te faire
une interview donc barthez soit nous
narre ses partenaires à la hugo qu'est
celui pour toi qui a le meilleur look
yann barthès one night stand encarta
thébaux que j'y réponds tu peux montrer
sur la pancarte où tu peux dire ok joker
je vais dire que des joker clichés si
vous nous rejoignez 21 heures oui là le
meilleur look tu prends pas de risques
c'est cyril audiard y est tu peux dire
yann basée à me dire jan non mais je
veux pas rentrer dans votre guerre là
non mais alors rien c'est bon je dois
rentrer dans ce truc la toiture et voilà
alors celui avec qui tu voudrais jamais
parti en vacances je pense que c'est moi
et ça c'est pas moi je veux partir en
vacances et avec ma femme alors là ya
une question
normalement tu peux pas tu peux répondre
lequel des deux le plus dark à yann
barthès ou hanouna ça veut dire quoi
d'arcade ce que je mangeais pas les pif
et rigolo le moal et rigolo le fou fou
fou fou ça doit dépendre des situations
aulas tu va en sortir un quoi qu'il
arrive ça n'arrivera pas cette émission
fait de la politique hugo alors
attention à la théorie g2 répond à celui
qui paye le mieux ses équipes ses
barthel swan la réponse mais je connais
pas les céleris si je vais donner un
indice la réponse commence par yann et
finit par barthez
[Rires]
une petite à une petite dernière
non franchement celui qui travaille le
plus selon toi c'est barthez ou another
year aussi tu peux lire non non non
l'animateur ne travaille jamais seul
c'est surtout le travail aussi de ses
équipes autour qui compte alors
franchement et hugo une dernière alors
lequel selon toi lequel selon toi peut
s'énerver le plus rapidement à ça je
pense que c'est vous
[Applaudissements]
en général il remercie tout d'abord est
avec lui